to the pandemic now three states are
allowing coronavirus booster shots for
all adults even though federal health
officials recommended limiting shots to
those patients considered most at risk
california colorado and new mexico have
some of the nation's highest coveted
rates of the new infections federal
health officials fear a possible winter
surge as more people move their
activities indoors it comes as the total
number of covet cases jumped two percent
over the past two weeks and the seven
day average of vaccinations climbed 25
percent over the last two weeks the
higher numbers come as the biden
administration lifts most visiting
restrictions at nursing homes michael
george is here now with the latest
michael good morning
good morning we're getting some signs
that covet is moving both north and west
for the winter states from new mexico
and colorado all the way up to michigan
and minnesota are seeing new spikes and
new hospitalizations are up primarily
among the unvaccinated
this is really a critical moment in the
pandemic it has never been more
dangerous for the unvaccinated than it
is right now to fight back governor
jared polis will allow coloradans of any
age to get a booster following
california that took the same step the
day before and in other states there are
calls to go beyond the age restrictions
the centers for disease control has
required i would recommend it for all
adults and i'm hopeful that we soon have
that policy here massachusetts where dr
paul sachs works saw daily cases go from
79 in july to over 1700 a day this week
the numbers are increasingly typical of
kovid's unpredictability we're in a an
odd place where we may be seeing a
version of our future
and i don't say that with any great joy
because we still have 25 000 cases a day
and a thousand deaths a day in the
united states dr robert walker is
chairman of the university of california
san francisco's department of medicine
as i look at the forces that are going
to make things better
more vaccinations boosters vaccinating
the kids maybe some new medications
coming i also see some counterbalancing
forces that make things worse people
becoming less careful
immunity waning i kind of think this may
be
a version of our life that we experience
for the next few years covet
hospitalizations rose in at least 14
states last week over the week before
michigan is at a six month high
and in unvaccinated areas in minnesota
regional hospitals are over taxed we are
essentially at 100 capacity we've been
that way for weeks and there's fear the
holidays ahead will bring anything but
joy my advice going into the holidays is
that anybody who's unvaccinated should
get vaccinated if i could wave a wand
and have everybody vaccinated within a
week this would go away
and on friday an appeals court upheld a
ruling that blocks the biden
administration's order that large
businesses either require vaccinations
or weekly testing the white house argued
that decision could lead to hundreds of
deaths but the court said the order was
too broad elaine michael george thank
you